Russian human rights activists say that
9 000 Russian soldiers have died since
the war in Ukraine began of these almost
300 are said to be men who have been
mobilized the Kremlin is far from its
goals in Ukraine many Russians are
concerned about that including those in
Putin's Inner Circle so what does that
mean for the war and for Putin's
political career DW correspondent Yuri
rashetto has this report
confusion about the reasons for going to
war few gains on the ground and the
chaos of mobilization the war in Ukraine
is not going well for Russia
the withdrawal of troops from house on
at the beginning of November was
moscow's biggest setback since the War
Began
hardliners in Moscow have been grumbling
ever since three of the loudest have
been businessman yevgeni pregocian
chechnyan leader ramzan kadirov
and former president Dimitri meliedev
[Music]
pragoshin one of Vladimir Putin's
closest confidants is making himself
especially noticeable
foreign
for years he denied the existence of his
mercenary Army the Wagner group
but recently he changed his story and
said he's been in charge of the
paramilitary organization since 2014
has two political instruments the Wagner
group and the media Outlets that have
helped him gain popularity and Status
he's a kind of external service provider
for the state he has some of the power
of the state and acts as a political
figure
in mid-september a video came out that
showed a man who looked like pragoshin
recruiting Russian prisoners to fight in
Ukraine
the reward freedom and money
who has been all over the headlines
since the War Began is ramzan khadirov
chechnya's leader has publicly
criticized Russia's generals for being
too soft
[Music]
is using the media to broaden his
influence
and to show everyone that he is a major
player
Chechen soldiers are fighting on
Russia's side in the donbass region
is being used by Putin just like
progression to recruit fresh troops for
the front lines
who served as president and prime
minister has been stoking the fires of
anti-western hatred
and making optimistic predictions that
Russia will win the war in Ukraine
um he's even said that nuclear weapons
are the way to give Russia back its
former Imperial Glory
he has a need for admiration the former
president who has become a nobody
I think he wants to earn political
Capital he seems to still have political
ambitions
just how much pragoshin kadiro
ahmediatev are putting President Putin
under pressure is unclear
but nine months into the war in Ukraine
displeasure is growing in Russia over
its course